hello and welcome to this session
of blockchain myself sora and i'm part
of the simply linkedin so let's get
started
what's in it for you today let's discuss
what is blockchain technology
and what are its features like public
distributed ledger
how encryption works proof of work
algorithm
and mining now what is blockchain
imagine two friends living
far away and would like to transfer
money using blockchain technology
blockchain is a decentralized system of
secure
and trusted distributed databases it's a
distributed ledger
which records and shares the transaction
details
across many nodes which are part of the
network
so that the data is not modified so each
and every transaction which happens on a
blockchain network it distributed
across all the nodes on the blockchain
each and every participant has the same
copy of the ledger
and it's an immutable ledger once a
record or a transaction is registered
it cannot be modified blockchain was
originally introduced to timestamp
digital documents
and prevent tampering of records in
simple terms
a chain of blocks that contain
information
is is called blockchain now when a
transaction occurs
its related information is recorded into
a
block so as you see a transaction
initiated in one corner of the globe can
get registered
on the block and then that block is
being verified
validated by the miners of the public
ledger and then added to the
main blockchain a block contains
aggregated
transactions in a single block which a
miner has to validate
and in lieu of that the miner gets
rewarded now let's take
a closer look at what all are the
components of a block so whenever we
talk about a blockchain
what is actually a block and what it
consists of now there are four major
components
each block contains a previous hash data
data is nothing but the aggregation of
the transactions
which are aggregated in the block a
nuanced value
and the hash of the block itself now
what is previous hash
previous hash is the attribute which is
connecting
a block to its previous block so the
previous hash
attribute consists of the hash value of
its previous block data it consists the
details
of the sender's address the receiver's
address and the transaction amount so
basically there could be multiple
transactions amongst multiple senders
and receivers
so each block will consist n number of
transactions and each transaction will
have a sender's address a receiver
address and a transaction amount
nonce so basically the bitcoin uses a
proof of work algorithm
and in order to execute the algorithm
nonce is a random value used to vary the
output
of the hash value so proof of work is
the process
of transaction verification done in
blockchain hash
hash is like a digital fingerprint it is
the fingerprint
of the current block now where it takes
an input value
of the previous hash the data and the
nonce
and produces an output value of fixed
length so bitcoin network
uses sha-256 hashing algorithm to
generate a 256 bit length hash
and this is the output it looks
something like a hexadecimal value now
what are the features of blockchain
a blockchain is a decentralized public
distributed ledger that is used to
record
transaction across many computers so
this is a sample
transaction which you are seeing there
is a set of three transactions a
transferring money to b b to c and c to
b a distributed ledger is a database
that is shared among all the users who
are part of the blockchain network
the transactions are accessed and
verified by users
associated to the bitcoin network
thereby making it
less prone to cyber attack it is
actually enclosed within
all the participants who are part of the
network now let's take an example
where these bitcoin users are
transferring money so here we have
example
like bella is trying to transfer money
to john john is trying to transfer money
to elsa
and elsa is trying to transfer money to
jack so these are the three transactions
which are to be initiated now suppose
these transactions
were being happening on a central ledger
and it gets corrupted so there is a
chance
of the data getting tampered to solve
this problem a public distributed ledger
plays a vital role now it ensures that
users part of the cycle have a copy of
the transaction details
each user will have a copy of
each transaction bella john elsa jack
they all have the same ledger and this
is what
is called as distributed ledger everyone
is having the
same copy now in case one of the users
like elsa misplaces her transaction
detail
she can easily be corrected by the other
participants because they have the
golden copy the correct copy or if
either of them attempts to alter the
record the alternate transaction copies
with the other users
will negate the alteration because they
will see
that amongst all the participants only
one participant is having a
different copy they will negate the copy
of the
user and they will rectify it encryption
blockchain eliminates
unauthorized access by using
cryptographic algorithm
sha-256 to ensure that the blocks are
kept secure so sha-256 is the
cryptographic algorithm which is used
each user
in the blockchain has their own keys so
any user which onboards a
typical blockchain network is always
provided with two set of keys one is
private one is public
private key is known only to the sender
also it is used to confirm if the origin
of the transaction is
legitimate public key it is also used to
uniquely identify the user
but it is shared by the sender with
every transaction it floats on the
blockchain network and we will see how
now let's take a look
at a typical transaction verification
process suppose a sender
wants to send a message he will pass the
message through the hash function
and generate a hash value of the message
now
after the hash value is being created it
is passed through a signature algorithm
and with the private key a digitally
signed document is created now the
transaction
message original message the digitally
signed document
and the public key are transmitted to
the receiver
now at the receiver end the transaction
message is passed through a hash
function to get a
hash value and that hash value is
compared with the hash value
obtained by passing the digital
signature and public key through a
verification function
and then both the values are compared
now let's see how the hash function
works
the hash function creates a unique
digital fingerprint of data
you pass the message through the hashing
function and it generates a hash value
this hash value is called a digital
print it has a very unique property
any hashing function is a one way
function it cannot be reversed
you cannot decode the original value
from the
hashed value it is a one way encryption
so here are some examples
whatever be the size of the input data
the hash value
is always of 256 bit length and we will
take a look at the demo
at the end of this session where i'll
show you how to generate
a hash value using sha-256 now let's
consider an example
of gmail using hashing algorithm
whenever you
are entering the username and password
that password is never
directly persisted in any of the gmail's
database
it is persisted using hashing function
so once you have created your password
and again once you log in
your password is again passed to the
hashing function
and compared with the hash value
persisted in the database
and once both these hash value matches
then only you are allowed to login so
every time you log into gmail your
password is hashed
into a value and compared against the
one
stored in the database the hash values
match with the one in database and then
the inbox is displayed on your screen
now let's take a look of what is the
proof of work algorithm
proof of work is a method to validate
transactions
in a blockchain network by solving a
complex
mathematical puzzle and this whole
process is called mining
finding the non's value is the
mathematical puzzle
that users or miners need to solve in
the bitcoin network so it takes huge
amount of computational power
and resources of the miner in order to
find out that nuance value users trying
to solve the puzzle
are called miners the puzzle is solved
by determining
a nonce that generates a hash value and
results an output lesser than a target
so in
any proof of work algorithm there is
always a target which is predefined for
a block
the miner has to use the nonce
in order to generate a hash which has to
be less than the target
miners verify transactions within a
block
and adds the block to the blockchain
when they have confirmed
and verified the transaction with proof
of work
miners compete against each other to
solve the mathematical puzzle
the first miner who solves the puzzle is
rewarded and when a block is solved
the transactions contained in a block
are also considered valid
and the bitcoins associated with the
transactions
then get deducted from the originator or
the sender
and moves to the receiver now let's see
how proof of work
works so let's take a look at the block
and its components
the previous block hash it stores the
hash value of the previous block of the
blockchain
data it contains the list of all the
transactions which have been aggregated
in the block
nonce is the random value which is used
to generate
a hash value less than the target and
hash
is the digital signature of the block
itself the hash
is generated using a hashing function
called sha-256
now using the nonce when the hash is
generated
if its output is less than the target
then the puzzle is deemed to be solved
the block is considered to be validated
if not then the miner increments the
nonce by value 1
and then again rehashes generate a hash
and
goes through the cyclic process till the
time it is not able to generate a hash
less than the target
in blockchain the target is adjusted
every two zero one six blocks which is
approximately every 14 days
the average time of block formation is
10 minutes and the difficulty target of
the puzzle
increases or decreases depending on the
time
it takes to mine the blocks so it is the
inbuilt network
which is generating the target for the
puzzle to get solved
and it fluctuates the difficulty based
on the time it takes to mind block proof
of work is hard to produce
but very easy for binders to verify so
point to be noted here is
once the block is hashed the remaining
miners
are supposed to validate the work which
one miner has
done but they are not required to find
the nonce again
so basically the miner who's supposed to
earn the bitcoin
has done the hard work but the others
miners on the network
just have to verify his validation in
blockchain
when miners use their resources time
money electricity etc
to validate a new transaction and record
them
on the public ledger they are given a
reward now that reward
is in bitcoins itself which as of today
stands at
12.5 bitcoins and to add there is no
other way
that the bitcoins can be generated in a
bitcoin network it is only through
mining
now the bitcoin network internally
halves the reward
after every 21k blocks which is
approximately every four years
so now subsequently whenever the time
period will end the mining reward will
get reduced to 6.25 btc
i hope you had a great learning session
and i'll meet you
in the next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here